upped his game in such a significant way
and improves what he's been doing on the
offensive side as you just see right
there
wild scene kevin durant pick up where he
left off
kyrie irving doing the same
triple from tyree irving and people have
throughout the course of his career this
isn't by accident that's not a fluke
shot with players that can move
a lot of use 12 guys on this roster 24
or younger is kyrie irving two for two
from long range
messy started the game shooting six for
eight from the floor
here's a rare appearance from kessler
edwards who checked in the ball game
during that free throw from kd
kyrie
gets it back three point in the corner
he's three for three from three
and just take a look at this play the
quickness of the hands get ahead
everyone's staying wide and push it and
then this is an excellent job here he
gets it that durant who just gives it
right back in the corner and they all
will and sometimes that is such a big
indicator for the magic of how they play
if they're knocking down those stretch
shots kyrie irving
even in the trees it's a high percentage
shot shooting the three well
[Applause]
kyrie irving squeezes it sets up the
offense
irving
working on carter jr swish
brooklyn shooting 71
from the floor blackstone wins the tip
irie irving good to see back on the
floor no issue with the hand as he
finishes off the window for the duke
i mean look at this he able to go right
past okiki then slices through wagner's
trying to do a job tenth season out of
washington
oh you know he can heat up in a hurry
a microwave in his own ride kyrie irving
to give
continuation
what a play from kyrie irving
well and look at this excellent screen
by claxton and then he just continues to
snake through
but he is up to 23
points
and backdoor cut there make it 25.
oh he's halfway to 50.
look at this beautiful pass by james
johnson on a dive up under that hang
time comes from
the strength of the core we see this
often from james johnson but
that's where i mean false
four minutes gone by in the second
fourth
irving crossover inside left hand
a magic trick
timeout orlando
look at this
smooth moves cut through the defense oh
what a finish
looking at the hand and kyrie is hitting
everything
than any other team in the association
this season and i think you add in their
excitement about the growth of wendell
carter jr and what he looks like just
happiness and his potential oh the midi
from kyrie irving he's up to 31. from
kyrie irving his window carter junior
can't get that default rebound drummond
irving had 30
and a half as he pulled up again and
knocks down the three
kyrie
irving it's the efficiency that he's
doing it at
the ease i mean
uh
but it hasn't just been isolations
again
cash out
in his 11-year nba career
again
are you kidding me
amway sitter get in the show
2 24 to go in this first half
are you not entertained
it's a 19-point game
that's it led by as many as 30 and
there's a foul count the bucket
a continuation
i i think the crowd is cheering kyrie
has turned the amway center into his
[Applause]
personal cheering section what a
beautiful play off the miss here comes
brooklyn brown
grant
inside brown and a little bit of trouble
quick release kyrie irving
48
and counting
[Applause]
irving on the move looking for 50 off
the window
kyrie is so cold
look at that
to even get to that point in the paint
impacts the yankees and the mets as well
so do not want to miss hot stove a lot
to cover
kyrie irving back in the ball game and
he's still
hot elgin baylor and jerry west
and admiral schofield had no chance i
know these fans came in wanting to see a
magic win but
your basketball fans first and foremost
and you're getting a show
foles is trying to
take away any air space it's just a
quickness of his movement
edwards
the handoff quick trigger irving 60
6d
kyrie irving take a look
bottoms
[Applause]
this has been a sight to see
and just a gorgeous display of all the
talents that we've continued to watch
throughout the course of kyrie's career
putting them all out there
devon vasel hasn't poked away by towns
the timberwolves come away with it
drop coverage from minnesota in the
first possession
knuckles and excellent rollers towns
going to his right hand how many times
we've seen him
kiss that off the class going to his
right karl anthony towns getting off to
a pretty good start in this one tonight
especially since the all-star break he's
below 25 percent since the rank
towns flushes
rises quickly for the for the dunk
[Music]
[Applause]
he's got a second dunk already inside
the restricted area in within five feet
of the basket
and murray's already got three dimes
for the top assist men in the nba towns
buries the three timberwolves can get it
two for one if they hurry
towns draws the contact chance for an
end
and the foul is going to go on zach
collins
that's a strong move man cat just is
moving people out of the way
spurs scoring lead for the night he's
got 13 thus far
towns
sticks with it finishes
and cats gonna get teed up
numbers for san antonio
[Applause]
and the wolves catch a break
towns gets paid off on the other end
tied at 61. there's the guy mop on the
floor getting out of the way maybe he
saw shacked in a pool last week he's so
good between the elbows knocking down
elbow
jumpers
from all over the floor edward's no
town's an offensive rebound back up and
in
cells five of eight carl's just not a
rim protector classically is but he
isn't an attacker yes he is
you can't stop him
but the defense
has not been the strong suit so far here
tonight
at the towns drills to three
[Applause]
attack mode catch and go
[Music]
knocks it free timberwolves get a stop
[Applause]
11 turnovers tonight for san antonio
drills it
nobody picks him up
and he'll take advantage
58 for san antonio 55 for minnesota
towns
moves the world shooting percentage
north a little bit towns is just showing
the floor so in this game
who's done it all tonight
pulls up in front of collins and drills
it 46 for cat
as much as they did that time they came
all the way out got into rotation left
the hot player open lonnie walker has
been really good in this game he's seven
of ten
towns he's got 49
[Applause]
towns
steps back drills to triple
make it 54 in the game
nine three-point attempts for carl
anthony towns in this game he's been
averaging three a game in the month of
march township
make it 32 in the quarter and he's tied
the franchise record 56
in the game
[Applause]
[Applause]
night yeah the skill of carl anthony
towns is off the charts
and in incredible for the nba to have
three bigs
with the talent level of towns